que utilizaba un sistema de código de color para determinar qué barrios
deberían recibir préstamos federales de vivienda y cuáles no.
Su mapa de seguridad residencial era su propio tipo de paleta de colores
y, de hecho, era más influyente
que todas las paletas combinadas que estudié en la universidad.
Los bancos no harían préstamos a gente que vivía en barrios como el mío.
Esa soy yo en D86.
Sus cartógrafos literalmente coloreaban estos mapas
y etiquetaban a ese color como "peligroso".
El rojo era el nuevo negro
y los barrios negros se teñían de color.
El problema continúa hoy día
y lo hemos visto recientemente en la crisis de ejecución hipotecaria.
Su mejor exponente en Chicago son estas X, que están estampadas
en las fachadas de casas desocupadas al sur y al oeste.
La realidad es que las paletas de colores ajenas determinaban
mi existencia física y artística.
Ridículo.
Decidí que crearía mi propia paleta de colores,
hablaría con la gente que vive donde vivo yo
y cambiaría la manera en que nos definieron los colores.
Era una paleta que no tenía que buscar muy lejos
ni en ningún tratado porque ya la conocía.
¿Qué tipo de pintor emerge de esta realidad?
¿De qué color es lo urbano?
¿De qué color es el gueto?
¿De qué color es el privilegio?
¿De qué color es lo pandillero?
¿De qué color es lo aburguesado?
¿Qué color representa Freddie Gray?
¿Qué color representa Mike Brown?
Por fin, encontré una manera de conectar
mi entendimiento racializado del color
con mi entendimiento teórico de este.
Y parí a mi tercer bebé:
"La teoría colorida".
(Risas)
La "teoría colorida" fue un proyecto artístico de dos años,
donde apliqué mi propia paleta de colores a mis propios barrios
a mi manera.
Ahora, si caminara por la calle 79 en este momento
y le preguntara a 50 personas el nombre de un tono de cian algo más verde,
me mirarían de reojo.
(Risas)
Pero si digo, "¿De qué color es Ultra Sheen?"
Ahí salen sonrisas,
emergen historias del cuarto de baño de su abuela.
Es decir, ¿a quién le hace falta el turquesa teniendo Ultra Sheen?
¿A quién le hace falta el verde azulado teniendo Ultra Sheen?
¿A quién le hace falta el ultramarino teniendo...
Público: Ultra Sheen.
(Risas)
Así es exactamente cómo obtuve mi paleta.
Les preguntaba a amigos y a familiares, a personas con un origen similar al mío,
por esas historias y recuerdos.
Las historias no eran siempre felices,
pero los colores siempre resonaban más que el producto en sí.
Llevé esas teorías a la calle.
"Ultra Sheen".
"Crema humectante rosa".
Si son de Chicago, "Harold's Chicken Shack".
(Risas)
"Casa de cambio + Paso seguro".
"Flamin' Red Hots".
"Loose Squares"
y "Crown Royal Bag".
Pinté casas que demolerían en breve
en un área aborrecida llamada Englewood.
Juntamos tanta pintura como pude meter en el maletero.
Llamé a mis colegas artistas de más confianza,
mi increíble esposo siempre a mi lado,
y pintamos cada cm del exterior de manera monocromática.
Quería entender la escala como no lo había hecho nunca.
Quería aplicar colores a los lienzos más grandes que pudiese imaginar,
las casas.
Conduje obsesivamente por calles conocidas y en las que me crié,
cotejé estas casas con el portal de datos de la ciudad para asegurarme
de que las habían marcado para demolerlas,
de que eran insalvables y las dieron por muertas.
En realidad, quería entender lo que significaba que dominase el color,
confiar en mi instinto, dejar de pedir permiso.
Nada de reuniones con autoridades municipales,
nada de compromisos comunitarios,
solo dejar que mandase el color
en mi deseo de ofrecer una imagen diferente de South Side.
Estas casas contrastaban notablemente con sus homólogas alineadas.
Pintábamos para que resaltasen como las piezas del Monopoly
en estos lugares.
Íbamos los domingos por la mañana temprano
y seguíamos hasta quedarnos sin pintura o hasta que alguien se quejaba.
"Oye, ¿tú pintaste eso?",
me preguntó un día un conductor mientras yo sacaba esta foto.
Yo, nerviosa:
"¿Sí?"
Su rostro cambió.
"Oh, pensaba que iba a venir Prince".
(Risas)
Él se había criado en esta manzana.
Imagínenselo cuando pasó conduciendo y vio
que una de las pocas casas que quedaban cambió de color de un día para otro.
Evidentemente, no se trataba de una bolsa de Crown Royal,
era un aviso secreto de Prince.
(Risas)
Y aunque esa manzana parecía de todo menos desaparecida,
la idea era que Prince podría aparecer en lugares inesperados
y dar conciertos gratis en áreas donde la industria musical y la sociedad
consideraban que ya no eran valiosas.
Para él,
la idea de que solo la imagen de esta casa
fuera suficiente como para traer a Prince
significaba que era posible.
En ese momento,
ese pedacito de Eggleston se convirtió en sinónimo de realeza.
Aunque fuese brevemente,
el barrio de Eric Bennett recuperó su valor.
A pesar de ser extraños, intercambiamos historias del instituto al que fuimos
y del lugar donde habíamos crecido, del quiosco de fulano y mengano,
de ser niños en South Side.
Y una vez que revelé que este proyecto no tenía nada que ver con Prince,
Eric asintió en acuerdo
y al separarnos, mientras se alejaba,
dijo, "¡Pero aún podría venir!"
(Risas)
Él se hizo cargo plenamente de este proyecto
y no estaba dispuesto a renunciar, ni siquiera a mí, su autora.
Para mí, eso era un éxito.
Ojalá pudiera decirles que este proyecto transformó el barrio
y todos los índices con los que nos gusta contar:
más trabajos, menos crimen, cero alcoholismo...
pero de hecho, es más gris que eso.
La "teoría colorida" catalizó nuevas conversaciones
sobre el valor de la oscuridad.
La "teoría colorida" hizo claramente visible las cuestiones incómodas
que las instituciones y los gobiernos deben preguntarse
acerca de porqué hacen lo que hacen.
Hacen preguntas igual de difíciles sobre mí y mis colegas del barrio
acerca de nuestros sistemas de valores
y de cuál tiene que ser nuestro camino hacia la acción colectiva.
El color me dio libertad de tal modo que no esperé ningún permiso,
ninguna afirmación ni ninguna inclusión.
El color era algo que podía dominar.
Uno de los miembros del barrio y miembro del equipo de pintura
lo expresó mejor cuando dijo: "Esto no cambió el barrio,
cambió la percepción de la gente sobre las posibilidades del barrio",
de todas las formas posibles.
Los transeúntes me preguntaban:
¿Por qué pintas esa casa si sabes que el ayuntamiento vendrá a demolerla?"
En ese momento, yo no tenía ni idea,
solo sabía que tenía que hacer algo.
Daría lo que fuera para entender mejor el color, como un medio
y como una forma inevitable de identificarme en la sociedad.
Si queda alguna esperanza de mejorar el mundo,
tengo que amar y aprovechar estas dos formas de entender,
y ahí radica el valor y la tonalidad.
Gracias.
(Aplauso)(Ovaciones)